a few years ago i sailed on a ship that
comes from an earlier era when moving
goods by sea didn't mean polluting the
planet
our voyage to the caribbean was
eye-opening and not just because i
learned that apparently i'm incurably
seasick
i also saw what it's like when you take
away the diesel fumes and the black
smoke that spew from today's freighters
and ports instead our vessel smelled
like fresh sea breeze and the bags of
cardamom we carried and all that
chamomile tea i was chugging
nearly every modern cargo ship relies on
highly polluting fossil fuels
fortunately there's a way to clean up
the industry beyond just reviving
old-fashioned sailing chips and it's
green pneumonia
if you know anything about ammonia it's
probably that it's stinky it's toxic
it's potentially explosive so that's a
great place to start right
ammonia is mainly used today to make
chemicals and fertilizers
but for many reasons industry experts
are convinced that ammonia could be a
game-changing way to drive giant cargo
ships and that it could be used safely
and be cost competitive
tens of thousands of freighters
crisscross the oceans every day bringing
the food we eat the clothes we wear the
cars we drive
container ships alone carry some four
trillion dollars with the goods by sea
every year that's roughly the gdp of
germany
at the same time the shipping industry
contributes a significant share of the
world's annual greenhouse gas emissions
if shipping were a country it'd be the
sixth largest emitter of co2 trailing
just behind japan
as world economies grow and populations
rise shipping's emissions are expected
to soar
unless the industry charts a cleaner
course
so green ammonia really first came to my
attention in 2017 at the u.n climate
change conference in bonn germany
at the panel i attended ammonia seemed
kind of like an aside or something we
should be keeping tabs on
since then the industry has really
coalesced around pneumonia as the next
dominant shipping fuel
chemical companies and investors are
spending millions of dollars to build
green ammonia plants
and ship builders and manufacturers are
busy developing the necessary technology
the first ammonia-powered chips are just
around the corner
so what's so special about this pungent
gas
well to start ammonia doesn't contain
any carbon molecules so it doesn't
create carbon dioxide when used as fuel
instead it contains one part nitrogen
which is the main component of air and
three parts hydrogen which is a building
block of water
it's possible to make ammonia without
using any fossil fuels that's what makes
it green ammonia
think of it like this so instead of the
oil wells and petroleum refineries that
make today's dirty diesel fuels picture
solar panels or wind turbines or
hydropower plants
renewable electricity is the foundation
of this whole ammonia making ordeal
we can start with electrolysis which
uses electricity to split water into
hydrogen and oxygen
then renewables can power the process
that separate nitrogen from air
and so with our hydrogen and nitrogen we
can combine the two in an industrial
process at high temperatures to make nh3
ammonia now if you want to use this
ammonia to power your 1000 foot long
freighter you have two options the first
is an internal combustion engine so
similar to how diesel is used in ships
today but with certain modifications
experts think that the the first vessels
to use ammonia in their engines will be
chemical tankers because they already
carry it in their cargo holds so they'll
be like the early adopters
the next option is to use a fuel cell
fuel cells create electricity through a
chemical reaction and that's what drives
the ship's motors in terms of propellers
in norway work is underway to launch the
world's first ammonia fuel cell ship in
just a few years time
so we can make green ammonia and we can
use it in fuel cells or engines
the final piece of the ammonia puzzle is
the infrastructure the storage
facilities the pipelines the
distribution networks everything that's
needed to ensure a ship can fill its
tanks anywhere in the world
and none of this is particularly novel
because we already have infrastructure
for the chemical and fertilizer
industries
now it just needs to be built near ports
and at a global scale and with great
caution
so what's needed to take ammonia
mainstream
we can draw a rough parallel to the rise
of electric cars
a decade ago about 17 000 dvs were on
the roads worldwide then more and more
countries adopted policies encouraging
people to buy evs supporting
manufacturers
and to build up charging infrastructure
and as sales climbed and production
boomed the cost of batteries and other
components plummeted making it easier
for more people to afford electric cars
so now instead of 17 000 dvs it's more
like 10 million and green pneumonia
could follow a similar path in the
shipping industry
policies to curb emissions and
incentivize green investments could spur
a shift away from fossil fuels
and as money catches on fuel prices and
technology costs could decline in step
enabling more ship operators to make the
switch
and while all of that is happening a
much bigger story will be playing out on
the global scale
the rising development and plunging
costs of renewable energy supplies
giant offshore wind farms sprawling
solar arrays and other technologies
could provide the electrons needed to
make all that green ammonia
green ammonia might be the the main fuel
source on future cargo ships but it
doesn't have to be the only clean
technology on board ships will likely
use a combination of tools
batteries can already power the lights
and equipment on giant ships and
certainly smaller vessels can be fully
battery powered today
design fixes like super sleek halls and
dolphin-like flippers can improve ship's
efficiency
and another technology that's quickly
gaining traction is called wind assisted
propulsion
which puts a modern twist on an old idea
of harnessing wind
one cargo ship i settled on in the north
sea uses devices called rotor sails
these are 60 foot tall tubes that spin
around like hyperactive barber's poles
which produces a forward thrust and
reduces demand on the diesel engines
it's really exciting to see these things
whip around but it's funny how almost
plase the crew was about the whole thing
they push a button the tube swirl to
life the ship saves fuel
and they can all carry on with their
normal tasks as we sailed from rotterdam
to this industrial eyesore in northern
england and back again
meanwhile of course i spent my time
admiring the sails and then curling up
in the fetal position as the sea knocked
our ship around
the maritime industry is at a pivotal
moment in its long and storied history
over the last few centuries fossil fuels
have powered the freighters that have
transformed global trade connecting
cotton fields to far flung garment
factories and bringing blueberries from
one side of the equator to the other
coal-powered steam ships made it
possible to travel farther and faster
and diesel engines took this into
overdrive
what began in the early 20th century as
a humble canal boat puttering along with
this tiny engine has since become giant
container ships that stretch as long as
skyscrapers stand tall
we know that to keep the planet from
warming further we must completely
transform the way that we power our
homes our cars and the freighters that
bring us all our precious stuff
the shipping industry must join the rest
of the world in addressing climate
change and it could do that with the
help of green pneumonia
thank you so much